>> Greg: IT EXPLODED ALL OVER
TWITTER.
KIDS AND HATS TAUNTING A
NATIVE AMERICAN MAN.
NOT SO FAST.
SOON AFTER, OTHER TAPES SURFACED
WHERE IT APPEARS THE TEENS WERE
DOING CHEERS WHEN APPROACHED BY
THE DRUMMER WHO BEAT THE
INSTRUMENT IN THEIR FACES.
THIS WAS AFTER DIFFERENT
ACTIVISTS HAD APPROACHED AND
HARASSED THE TEAM.
WITH MORE INFO, THIS NEWS STORY
SEEMS DIFFERENT AND THE OLD
STORY, HOW DID THAT HAPPEN
QUESTION.
THE MEDIA EMBRACED THE STORY
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
WE CAN'T RESIST BEING FIRST.
CAN'T RESIST BEING SECOND.
ANYWAY THE MEDIA WAS PROVIDED
THEIR FAVORITE VILLAIN, THE RED
CAP.
FOR THE PRESS, YOU CAN'T SPELL
HEAT WITHOUT HAT.
I CAME UP WITH THAT TODAY.
PRETTY GOOD?
THE MEDIA KNEW THIS STORY ALSO
WOULD DISTRACT FROM THE BUZZFEED
MASS.
I SAW THE STORY UNFOLD, AND
TRUSTING MY OWN EYES, I SAW
OBNOXIOUS TEENS.
MY CHAPERONE INSTINCT KICKED IN.
IF I AM CRITIQUING LIBERALS ALL
DAY, I SHOULD ALSO POLICE
BY THE WAY, ISN'T THAT THE BIG
QUESTION HERE?
WHERE WERE THE CHAPERONES?
I ALWAYS HAD THEM WHEN I WAS IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
I DESERVE THEM.
I SAID THE KID SHOULD APOLOGIZE
BUT MAYBE IT SHOULD BE MADE FOR
JUMPING THE GUN.
HOWEVER, I DO KNOW THIS STORY
HAS CHANGED ONCE AND IT'S GOING
TO CHANGE AGAIN WHICH IS WHY
IT'S UP TO US AND TO ME NOT TO
TAKE THE BAIT WHEN WE ARE BORED
OR POSSIBLY DRINKING ON A
SATURDAY AFTERNOON.
I HAVE SAID IT BEFORE.
ALWAYS BE SKEPTICAL.
NOBODY KNOWS WHERE HER STORY
GOES.
THAT'S GREAT ADVICE I GAVE.
NEXT TIME I'LL TAKE IT.
I HAVE A QUESTION, DANA.
THE BIG STORY OR ONE OF THE BIG
STORIES TODAY, CELEBRITIES AND
MEDIA TYPES TAKING DOWN THEIR
TWITTER IN WHICH THEY WERE
BASHING THESE KIDS.
I LEFT MINE UP.
I THINK TAKING SOMETHING DOWN IF
YOU THINK IT'S WRONG --
IF A TWEET ENDANGERS SOMEBODY,
YOU SHOULD TAKE IT DOWN BUT YOU
SHOULD LEAVE HER FOOTPRINTS UP
UNTIL YOU TAKE IT ALL AWAY.
>> Dana: IN SOME WAYS, YOU
KNOW HOW I COMPLAINED THAT IN
THE MEDIA SOMETHING WILL HAPPEN
AND THEN THERE'S A CORRECTION
BUT THE CORRECTION ONLY GETS
ONE-TENTH OF THE ATTENTION IS
THE ORIGINAL ARTICLE.
I COULD SEE WHERE YOU MIGHT WANT
TO TAKE IT DOWN.
BUT IT DOES RAISE AN INTERESTING
QUESTION.
TRYING TO ERASE IT SO THIS WHOLE
FIGHT IN EUROPE, DO YOU HAVE A
RIGHT TO BE FORGOTTEN?
ONE THING YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO DO
IS YOU DON'T HAVE TO TWEET.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO IT, BUT YOU
SHOULD COME AS AN ADULT IN
PARTICULAR, HAVE TO OWN WHAT YOU
SAY.
IF YOU GOT IT WRONG, YOU SAY I
GOT IT WRONG.
>> Greg: JESSE, THE SCHOOL MAY
SUE FOR SLANDER.
I ALSO SAW THAT ON TWITTER.
IT SOUNDS LIKE -- DO THEY HAVE A
CASE?
>> Jesse: SUING FOR SLANDER IS
TOUGH.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO SO
EVERYBODY FOR SLANDER.
HAS HE BEEN SUCCESSFUL?
PROBABLY NOT.
THIS WAS ONE OF YOUR BEDROOM
MONOLOGUES, -- THIS IS ONE OF
YOUR BETTER MONOLOGUES.
WHAT DID YOU DO DIFFERENTLY?
HERE IS MY TAKE.
THIS STORY BECAME A CONTROVERSY
BECAUSE THE GUY SMIRKED.
AS A SMIRK OR, I WOULD LIKE TO
DEFEND SMIRKING.
SMIRKING IS NOT A HATE CRIME.
WHEN I AM AMUSED OR CONTENT OR
CALM.
SOMETIMES IT IS USED TO DEFUSE
THE SITUATION.
IT'S A NONVIOLENT THING.
BUT PEOPLE HATE BEING SMIRKED
AT.
I HAVE OFTEN BEEN SAID THAT I
HAVE THE MOST PUNISHABLE FACE ON
TELEVISION.
>> Greg: I HAVE EVEN SAID THAT
TO YOU.
>> Jesse: PEOPLE SAY IT ON
TWITTER ALL THE TIME.
WHEN I WAS LOOKING AT THE STORY,
PEOPLE SAYING THAT THIS KID HAS
THE MOST PUNCHABLE FACE, BESIDES
JESSE WATTERS.
SMIRKING ELICITS THIS REACTION.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, THE BLACK
HEBREW ISRAELITES ARE NOT
GETTING ANY ATTENTION.
THEY ARE THE ONES.
SOME OF THE MOST RACIST, HATEFUL
PEOPLE YOU WILL EVER ENCOUNTER
IN YOUR WHOLE LIFE.
I UNDERSTAND WHY THESE KIDS WERE
CHANTING AND TRYING TO CREATE A
COUNTER PROTEST.
>> Greg: TO JESSE'S POINT
ABOUT THE GROUP, I USED TO SEE
THEM IN TIMES SQUARE ALL THE
TIME.
WHAT IS THEIR RELIGION, WHAT'S
THEIR ISSUE?
>> Juan: BASICALLY WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING IS THEY ARE THE
REAL ISRAELITES.
THEY ARE THERE REAL PEOPLE WHO
ARE THE CHOSEN ONES, NOT JEWISH
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE ALL SORTS OF ELABORATE
MYTHOLOGY, IDEOLOGY RELIGIOUS
THEORY THAT PUTS THEM AT THE
CENTER OF THE UNIVERSE.
THEY DO SAY HATEFUL THINGS AND
THEY CAN BE THREATENING.
BUT WHAT YOU HEARD HERE
INITIALLY WAS THAT THE
NATIVE AMERICAN ELDER SAID THERE
ARE ONLY FOUR OF THE ISRAELITES
AND THERE WAS A BIG GROUP OF
KIDS IN THE MAGA HATS AND ALL
THE REST.
THE ISRAELITES WERE SAYING THE
OFFENSIVE THINGS AND THEN THE
KIDS WERE STARTING TO COME BACK
AND SCREAMING AT THEM.
>> Greg: I JUST SAW THEM
LAUGHING.
>> Juan: CHANTING OR WHATEVER
THE HIGH SCHOOL CHANT WAS.
>> Greg: THEY NEVER SAID
"BUILD A WALL," OR WHATEVER.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
HE TOLD REPORTERS HE INTERVENED
TO STOP THE HIGH SCHOOL KIDS
FROM ATTACKING WHAT HE DESCRIBED
AS THESE FOUR BLACK EYES.
THEN WE SEE SUBSEQUENTLY MAYBE
NOT THE CASE.
WHAT STRIKES ME IS THAT BOTH THE
ROMAN CATHOLIC HIGH SCHOOL AND
THE DIOCESE BOTH INITIALLY
APOLOGIZED BASED ON WHAT WE
FIRST SAW.
>> Greg: I AGREE.
I THOUGHT THEY SHOULD --
I SAW THE INITIAL STUFF AND MY
FIRST THING WAS I DIDN'T SEE THE
ADULTS THERE.
NOW WHAT WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
IS WHAT HAPPENS TO THIS KID, THE
STUDENT WHOSE FACES EVERYWHERE
AND IS GETTING DEATH THREATS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Jedediah: HE IS SAYING THAT
HE AND HIS FAMILY ARE GETTING
DEATH THREATS.
I WATCHED TWO HOURS OF THIS
VIDEO FROM THREE DIFFERENT
ANGLES AND I DID FIND IT
FASCINATING THAT THE ONLY
THING --
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
SMIRK ON THE CHANTING AND YOU
COULD ARGUE, THIS IS A BUNCH OF
HIGH SCHOOL BOYS AND THEIR
PARENTS MAY BE NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THEM ABOUT
WHEN YOU ARE IN A CHAOTIC OR
ANTAGONISTIC SITUATION, JUST
WALK AWAY.
DON'T STAND THERE.
DON'T STEER SOMEBODY DOWN.
WHAT IF THE KIDS, FROM WHAT WE
KNOW, WHAT DID THEY DO?
THERE IS NO ASSAULT.
YOU HAVE THE BLACK HEBREW
ISRAELITES SHOUTING ANTI-GAY
SLURS, RACIST SLURS.
THEY CALLED THEM YOUNG KLANSMEN,
SCHOOL SHOOTERS.
THEY DO THAT BEFORE AND AFTER
THE ENTRANCE OF NATHAN PHILLIPS.
IT LOOKS LIKE A CHAOTIC SCENE.
I WATCHED FROM EVERY ANGLE AND I
DIDN'T SEE NATHAN PHILLIPS GET
SURROUNDED BY THEM IN A MENACING
WAY.
I SAW HIM WALK RIGHT INTO THE
SCENE.
I THINK IN THE AGE OF TWITTER,
IT'S HARD BECAUSE SEE THE STORY
AND YOU'RE RIGHT YOU WANT TO
JUMP, YOU WANT TO COMMENT.
I WAS SURPRISED TO SEE -- I HAVE
TO COMMENCE ON REPORTERS.
THERE WERE SOME REPORTS ON OTHER
NETWORKS TO JUMP TO CONCLUSIONS
AND WALKED IT BACK AND SAID
LISTEN, I SHOULDN'T OF DONE
THAT.
WHEN YOU WATCH THE WHOLE VIDEO,
IT'S SO CLEAR THESE KIDS ARE
BEING ANTAGONIZED.
HOW THEY RESPONDED, YOU COULD
SAY, WASN'T MATURE.
I DON'T ASK FOR TO HIGH SCHOOL
TEENAGER TO BE MATURE.
AS OF NOW, THE AMOUNT OF
COVERAGE THEY GOT FOR ROOT
EXPRESSION VERSUS WHAT THE BLACK
ISRAELITES HAD, IT'S
ASTONISHING.
>> Greg: I THINK IF WE LEARNED
ANYTHING, THERE'S A FUTURE
JESSE WATTERS OUT THERE.
>> Jedediah: AND HE'S GOT THE
HAT.